April the 15th 2013 2 bombs tear through
the crowd welcoming runners over the
finish line at the Boston Marathon the
carnage is total with three people
killed and dozens wounded within hours
the FBI have identified a pair of
suspects the two brothers are immigrants
to America whose parents had fled the
violence of Chechnya to give their
children a better life so how did it all
go so wrong today through the story of
the younger of the two brothers Dzhokhar
tsarnaev we find out sugar and
czarevitch tsarnaev was born on July the
22nd 1993 in Kyrgyzstan his parents were
anzo and Zuba dad sana and salt was a
cattle farm laborer in the caspian
region of Kalmykia and Zuma dirt was the
city girl who struggled to fit into the
rural community life that marriage gave
her her spirits were lifted with the
birth of the first child in October of
1986 the couple names the boy Tamlyn
after the great Asian Conqueror zoo bird
aunt was a doting mother she always
dressed Tamerlane who was nicknamed
Tammy in the best attire the boy did
well in school his mother put pressure
on her husbands have move in order to
provide their son with wider
opportunities they returned to Ansel's
hometown and moved in with his parents
about a year later and Zoe's father he
was killed in a work accident this left
him as the family patriarch with the
collapse of the Soviet Union life in the
region it changed dramatically labourers
became entrepreneurs overnight as the
Western economy began flooding in and
saw founded job as a car repairman he
was making a living but in order to
really get ahead he realized that he had
to move to the newly created Republic of
Chechnya which seems like the new
promised land the family which now
included two daughters moved to Chechnya
in 1992 it was there that their second
son jogo was born he was named after the
charismatic presidents of Chechnya do
guard duty EV within just a year though
things had gone horribly wrong the
Russians invaded Chechnya and the
Sonya's found themselves in the middle
of a war zone
the family piled into a battles old
scooter and drove back to Kyrgyzstan as
the old family home in knock knock they
settled back into their old lives while
also making plans to
out of Eastern Europe their goal that
was America and Zoran Zuba dad believed
that their chances of getting to America
would be improved if they obtained some
educational credentials as a result they
both began studying law part-time after
four years in hoc marker they sold the
family home then moved not to America
but to Zumba dad's hometown of Dagestan
however it seemed as if his family were
unable to escape from war and before
long the streets were filled with
gunfights and explosions the Sarnia
family moved once again and Zoran Zuba
dad took Jirga with them on a trip to
the United States
Tamerlan along with the two daughters
was left with their uncle in Kyrgyzstan
they traveled on a 90 day tourist visa
during that visit and Zoar applied for
political asylum claiming that his life
was in danger due to his connections
with Chechnya the application was
submitted and the family were allowed to
stay until a decision was reached the
sally ever said chosen to come to Boston
Massachusetts that was when some friends
had moved a previous year so at least
they would know somebody they moved in
with this couple and the eight-year-old
jag är began attending second grade in a
public school along with the tube of
children in April of 2002 and thought
managed to find an inexpensive apartment
in Cambridge Massachusetts and they
moved out of the bf home and into their
own place jogo was left with the BFS for
the meantime in order to not interrupt
his school year and Zoran Zuba -
presented themselves as prospective
lawyers even though their studies had
been minimal when people asked they told
them that they were fleeing from ethnic
strife they found a kindred spirit in
their landlord Johanna Herlihy who took
them under her wing she took Zuba
daughter to an amnesty international
events focused on human rights abuses in
Chechnya and even paid for her to
enrolled in a Harvard Extension course
on negotiation and Zoar picked up under
the table jobs fixing cars for $10 an
hour when the school year was over
Jagger came to live with his parents in
Cambridge his time with the BFS had been
challenging his parents insisted that
the only language spoken in the home was
Chechen which he could barely understand
when the parents weren't around the
children would speak Russian he learned
English from his association with
American kids at school picking it up at
an amazing pace Jirga became an accepted
member of the chattering community of
children in the local area he was a good
student he made quick advancements in
fact during his
second year at school he was bumped up
from the third grade to the fourth in
mid-2003 the sea olives asylum
application it was granted the three
children left kyrgyzstan and we're now
free to join their family in the
promised land with the family reunited
things were looking pretty good for the
immigrant family both answer and Zuba
dad were working and they had permanence
and affordable accommodation Yoga is
remembered as a sweet lovable boy he was
described as being charming his teachers
described him as being bright but
lacking in the ability to think
creatively for himself he tended to say
things that got other people to like him
in 2003 jaga entered the fifth grade his
sister's 13 year old leaner and 15 year
old Bella were in seventh and ninth
grade 17 year old Tamlyn was in 10th
grade
the landlady Johanna tutored the
children in English and took them to
movies and let them watch DVDs
Tamlyn augmented his studies with
johanna by reading Sherlock Holmes
stories being the oldest son Tamerlan
was the focus of the family's plans for
success he was the golden haired child
the one he was destined for greatness he
was tall muscular and handsome even the
Americans saw something special in him
and zall decided that before heading off
to college his oldest son would become a
champion boxer Tamerlan proved himself
to be a gifted fighter yet a very
unconventional stance with his arms
hanging down rather than in a defensive
stance after training with his father
for a while he turns up at a local
martial arts gym
yep no mouthpiece helmet or other
protective gear and claims that he
didn't need them when he got into the
ring he proved it his stated admission
was to win a spot on the US Olympic team
and to use that position as a way of
becoming a naturalized US citizen tower
lands first victory in a boxing
competition was achieved in January of
2004 it was a Golden Gloves amateur
bowed head in lau massachusetts then his
poster victory interview he said I like
the USA you have a chance to make some
money here if you are willing to work in
2006 Tamerlan was enrolled at Bunker
Hill Community College for two years he
focused on his studies then in 2009 he
returned to boxing within a year he had
made it onto the Nash
amateur boxing circuit in 2010 he won
the Rocky Marciano trophy for winning
the New England Golden Gloves
competition but because he wasn't a US
citizen he was ineligible to fight for
the national title this was the severe
blurred Tamland and it caused him to
just give up on his boxing career by
that time
Tamerlan had also dropped out of college
his focus was now on becoming a music
star he began dressing flamboyantly with
one person describing his looks as that
of an Italian gigolo while American
teenage boys might have mocked his looks
the girls were entranced and he had no
shortage of female admirers in 2011
Tamlyn the great hope of that Sonia
family was a failed boxer a college
dropout and a father he was still living
at home with his parents but his
girlfriends and child were not for money
he delivered pizzas part-time and sold
marijuana on the site it was not exactly
the career path that his parents had in
mind
despite their initial efforts to
integrate into American society by 2011
that tsarnaev's had given up on trying
after struggling with the language with
the culture and even with buying things
on credit they reverted back to what
they were comfortable with they decided
to live as Chechens transplanted their
home at the typical chechen luke
oriental rugs large plush sofa and a
mirrored credenza housing plates things
had not planned out like they envisioned
their neighbors they viewed them with
suspicion if not without right hostility
their son was dealing drugs both their
daughters vented in to disastrous
marriages and hands or was spending his
days fixing old cars in the street
[Music]
in mid-2011 jagger graduated from Rindge
college and moved to the University of
Massachusetts at Dartmouth where he
lived on campus a couple of months later
his parents they filed for divorce by
now all of the rest of his family had
become disillusioned with their life in
America but not Chaca he continued to
make good grades and establish solid and
positive friendships he maintained his
friendly happy outlook at college he
joined the wrestling team he impressed
his coaches with his humility and
constant requests at what he could do to
improve it was a marked contrast to the
American boys on the team who did not do
this before long he was the captain of
the wrestling team
just like his older brother however -
car was smoking and also selling dope
yes his image of the pure sweet teenage
boy it was so complete that no one had
any inkling that this was the case
Jagger develops a friendship with one of
the college's most respected professors
Larry Aronson was the college's official
photographer Aronson adopted Jagger as
the poster child for kids from war-torn
zones who were now attending Rindge
College he also helped the boy come up
with a more American friendly version of
his name jaha Aronson was interested in
engaging Joker in discussions about what
was going on in Chechnya but the
teenager had no desire to talk about his
old country Aronson said whenever I
tried to talk to him about being Chechen
it meant nothing to him
[Music]
meanwhile Johar's old brother tamerlin
was moving in the other direction
in January of 2012 he flew to Dagestan
he went to his old hometown of Makkah
kala this was the capital of Dagestan
and over the last 10 years it had
transformed into a modern city
Tamlyn quickly fit into the social scene
spending his days mixing with fervent
young men in their 20s and 30s who
talked about their religion their
aspirations and the injustice 'as in the
world he met many of his relatives a
number of whom were involved in
organized crime
Tamlyn joins a group called union of the
just which was allied to the his aboot
area one of the largest Islamic
organizations in the world
he told members of the group that
America was a racist country that was
deeply divided with corrupt police and a
xenophobic foreign policy when asked to
compare America with Russia
Tamerlan is reported to have said I
refused to choose between two kinds of
fecal matter both taste like shit in
Tamlyn told his associates that he
urgently needed to return to the United
States because he had a problem with his
documentation he intimated that he had
no desire to go back and he would return
soon Tamerlan returned to Cambridge to
discover that his father had himself
returned to Dagestan and had started a
successful car repair business with his
brother a couple of weeks later zuid art
also returned to Dagestan not to reunite
with her ex-husband but to live with her
own family to Tamlyn Dagestan it was now
home he would only stay in the US long
enough to get his passport jonah Herlihy
that landlord had become increasingly
concerned with the radicalization of the
family after a heated encounter with
Tamerlan in which he vented about his
hatred of America she issued them an
eviction notice
back at college jaha got a new roommate
andrew dwinelle was a young American
go-getter the engineering major was
going places and his very presence
highlighted to jaha
just how inadequate he really was the
two never spoken only exchanged messages
when one of them was locked out of the
room jaha had a small and tight-knit
group of friends all of them being
Eastern European there was also a steady
flow of customers to his dorm room in
order to buy pot within a few months
jaha a social circle had widened
slightly to include a couple of
Americans they congregated off-campus at
the apartments of a couple of members of
the group once jaha disclosed to a
couple of members of their group that he
knew how to make a bomb he also said
that door parts of the Koran that were
worth fighting for with force still he
was not a Muslim extremist though those
in his group who had met his brother
considered Tamerlan to be one Patriots
Day 2013 occurred on April the 15th it's
a public holiday in Massachusetts and
it's the day that the Boston Marathon is
run two hours after the start of the
marathon at 2:49 p.m. as runners were
streaming across the finish line two
bombs exploded near the end of the
course three people were killed and 264
others were wounded in the immediate
aftermath of the bombing the police
scanned the crowd in an attempt to
identify anyone who looked out of place
the first target was a Saudi Arabian man
who had actually been wounded in the
blasts he was quickly cleared and then
three other Muslim men were looked at
but all were dismissed on Thursday April
the 18th the Washington Post published a
photo on its front page with a banner
that read bagman feds seek these two
pictured a Boston Marathon the two men
were Tamerlan and jahar tsarnaev when
Larry Aronson picked up the paper he
thought that one of the men looked
amazingly like Johar then when students
at the university saw the picture they
didn't think that it looks like jaha
they were convinced that it was him
still his friends couldn't believe that
he had been involved in the bombing he
just didn't seem capable of such a thing
rather than going to the police or the
FBI his friends went to Joe's door but
the door was locked
unable to locate Joe Harris friends went
back to their dorm and proceeded to play
xbox a short time later one of them
received attacks from Java that read if
you want you can go to my room and take
what's there they returned to the room
used a spare key to get in and began to
search his side of the room one of them
found
backpack that contained a large metal
cylinder and half an empty jar of
Vaseline he turned to his friends and
sent I think he used these to make the
bomb the FBI had been focused on jaha as
early as Wednesday morning they had been
studying video of the aftermath of the
explosions and it was noticed that jaha
didn't react to the blasts while
everyone else ran ducked and screamed he
just kept right on walking they also
noticed tunnel on walking alongside
showing no sign of reaction but the
problem was they had no idea where these
men were the images they were issued to
the American public with a warning that
they were considered to be armed and
extremely dangerous in the hours
following the bombing local media blamed
the pair for every crime committed in
the area including the murder of an MIT
police officer they got that last
accusation right
the brothers killed officer Sean Collier
in order to steal his gun they then
committed a carjacking at a Cambridge
gas station they were driving a Mercedes
SUV that they were unaware that it was
fitted with a GPS device this allowed
the police to track their every movement
they seemed to be driving around
aimlessly which they were because they
had no plan of action post bombing in
their possession the brothers had five
homemade explosive devices a
semi-automatic handgun a machete and a
hunting knife
they closed in on the brothers in a
quiet suburban street in the suburb of
Watertown and began randomly firing one
of the officers was seriously wounded by
friendly fire the brothers were behind
cover and when ordered to give up jaha
threw the explosive devices towards the
cops they exploded harmlessly in the
street the final shootout was between
Tamerlan and Watertown police officer
named Jed parolees the officer scored
several body hits while Tamerlan failed
to find his target when his ammunition
ran out he threw his gun at the officer
he then decided to flee and the officers
chased him they soon got to him and
dragged him to the grounds but now jihad
jumps behind the wheel of the SUV and
proceeded to run down the officers they
quickly jumped aside and jaha
unwittingly ran over the top of his
brother dragging the body thirty feet
down the street leaving his brother
dying on the road to hospital way it
took nearly a minute for the police to
give chase by then ditched the car and
run off into the suburbs the police
officers they scoured backyards in
dozens of suburbs and thousands of
people were ordered to evacuate their
homes a Watertown homeowner reported
seeing blood on the side of a boat in
his yard a SWAT team rushed to the house
Johar had been hiding in the covered
boat for hours the officers attempted to
coax him out with tear gas when that
failed they fired bullets to scare him
out in the ends and imposing officer
approached the boat and demanded that he
come out immediately a childish voice
replied but it's going to hurt police
officers then moved in and helped Jehan
make his way down from the boat he was
severely wounded with either bullet or
shrapnel injuries to the neck Aaron
thigh he was rushed to hospital where he
was operated on according to one of his
nurses he cried out for two days
straight after his operation when the
police searched the inside of the boat
that had been Johar's final hideout they
found the following message written in
blood the bombings were in retribution
for the us crimes in places like Iraq
and Afghanistan that the victims of the
Boston bombing were collateral damage in
the same way innocent victims have been
collateral damage in u.s. wars around
the world john's trial began on January
the 5th 2015 he was charged with four
counts of murder along with 26 other
charges
the prosecution they sought the death
penalty even though Massachusetts had
outlawed the death penalty in 1988 the
federal charges made it possible he pled
not guilty to all of the charges the
defense position was that Tamerlan had
been the master
of the enterprise and that Johar had
been coerced into cooperating
Sally showed no emotion throughout the
trial until his family members took the
stand at that point he wept on April the
8th 2015 Johar was found guilty on all
30 charges a month later he was
sentenced to death by lethal injection
he now sits in the notorious supermax
prison ADX Florence in Fremont County
Colorado meanwhile his defense team are
working on an appeal to his death
sentence so I hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and do not forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
like this several times a week if you
looking for something else right now
though why not check out my other
channel called top tens you'll find a
link to that in the description below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]